مشاهدينا للخبر العاجل الذي اوردناه قبل
قليل حول دوي انفجار قوي في خليج حيفا قرب
مصافي تكرير النفط هذه اذا اولى الصور
التي وردتنا وقد نقلت الخبر وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه هذه صور ايضا اضافيه تظهر
الدخان الذي
تصاعد عقب هذا الانفجار الذي سوع ذويه
بشكل كبير في خليج حيفا قرب مصافي تكرير
النفط
ز هديت الله
فقعت لا اطلع اطل
اطلع
ايش هذا هذا الصروخ
الامانه شوز خبط بالفعال
كلهل معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد هل من تفاصيل اضافيه حول
ما حدث في
حيفا المعلومات الاوليه تتحدث عن ان
انفجارا وقع وسمع دويه على مسافات بعيده
في موقع مصاف في تكرير البترول في خليج
حيفا حتى الساعه لم تتضح اسبابه او
خلفياته لكن الحديث هنا عن منطقه غايه في
الحساسيه فيها الكثير من المنشات ال البتر
كماويات ومصافي البترول والمصانع وهي
منطقه الخليج التي تقع بين حيفا وعكا في
منطقه الشمال هذه المنطقه سبق وان كانت قد
استهدفت بمسيرات او صواريخ وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه اعترض في الماضي لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه هذا الانفجار خلفيته لم تتضح
بعد لكن الحديث كما جاء سواء من شهود عيان
او من مصادر اوليه هو ان الانفجار وقع في
منطقه مصافي تكرير البترول في خليج حيفا
وليس واضحا ايضا ما اذا هناك اصابات ام
اضرار في المنطقه حتى الساعه كما قلت هذه
المنطقه قريبه من منطقه الحدود مع لبنان
منطقه راس الناقوره نحو 40 كومت او اقل
بقليل وكانت قد استهدفت في مرات سابقه لكن
الجيش كان يقول في كل مره بانه تمكن من
اعتراض سواء مسيرات قدمت من لبنان او
صواريخ اطلقت من الجنوب اللبناني باتجاهها
وكانت دائما صافرات الانذار تدوي في هذه
المنطقه سواء في مدينه حيفا او مدينه عكا
او منطقه الخليج او منطقه الجليل الغربي
التي تحدها من المنطقه الشرقيه يعني ليس
حتى واضحا ما اذا كان الامر يتعلق بحادث
هجومي او حادث عرضي
صحيح حتى الساعه هذا حدث في الدقائق
القليله الاخيره حتى الان ليس واضحا ما
اذا كان عارضا فقط او خلل ام انه بفعل
فاعل ام ان هناك قصف او مسيره ربما وصلت
الى المنطقه حتى هذه الساعه المعلومات
الاوليه كما قلت هي تتحدث عن ان دوي
انفجار وقع وسمع في هذه المنطقه الصناعيه
الهامه والتي تقع بين
منطقه حيفا وعكا تحديدا قريبه من منطقه
التشيك بوست في على مدخل حيفا الشرقي
لكنها هي في المنطقه الممتده بين حيفا
وعكا والمعروفه بخليج حيفا وفيها الكثير
من المناطق والمنشات الصناعيه بما فيها
مصافي تكرير البترول وهي مصافي قديمه جدا
كانت قد انشات في عهد الانتداب البريطاني
وكانت تاتي اليها البترول من من منطقه
كركوك في العراق في حينه لكن عندما جلى
الانتداب البريطاني عن هذه البلاد ورثها
الى دوله اسرائيل التي كانت ناشئه حديثا
في هذه المنطقه كان هناك برجان كبيران
احدهما انهار قبل نحو اكثر من عامين ب
جراء عدم الصيانه كما يبدو لكن الثاني بقي
موجودا وبقيت تعمل كمصاص لتكريم البترول
الان هذا الحدث الجديد المعلومات الاوليه
هي عن سماع دوي انفجار لم تتضح معالمه حتى
اللحظه نعم وما اذا كان بفعل فاعل ام انه
كان عارضا او نتيجه خلل